[Musique]
on va en parler du tunnel et de tous ces
défis dans le cadre de notre CA du
vendredi avec Mona Lisa prospère avocate
directrice de programme en
entrepreneuriat bonsoir Mona Lisa
bonsoir et Fanny Tremblay rassicot qui
est professeur adjointe à l'ENAP
directrice associée au centre de
recherche sur la gouvernance Fanny
bonsoir bonsoir Gérald c'est un immense
chantier Fanny qui commence et qui va
s'étirer sur trois longues années dans
le tunnel Louis Polyte la fontaine et on
a commencé en entendre parler on a
l'impression il y a à peine quelques
semaines est-ce qu'on l'a échappé comme
on dit est-ce qu'on pouvait faire mieux
en matière de planification
on pourrait dire que oui on aurait pu
faire mieux en matière de planification
en matière de communication aussi c'est
qu'on se base beaucoup sur les choix
individuels mais les choix individuels
sont conditionnés sont conditionnés par
le prix sont conditionnés par les
options qu'on a donc ici pas assez
d'options qui s'offrent aux individus
pour utiliser d'autres modes que l'auto
solo ben ils ont pas de plan B ils ont
pas de plancher guitariste d'être le
plan e le plan échec et les gens vont
continuer à prendre leur voiture il va y
avoir de la congestion qui va continuer
donc je pense que du point de vue de la
communication ça aurait pu commencer un
peu plus tôt puis aurait pu avoir
davantage d'options qui soient offertes
quoi mais je suis du même avis en fait
puis moi j'ajouterai que il y a une
opportunité ratée d'avoir une campagne
beaucoup plus agressive qui démontre aux
automobilistes ceux qui gagnent en
utilisant les transports en commun je
pense que les mesures en place sont des
bonnes mesures c'est des mesures
importantes mais on demande à plus de
120 000 automobilistes de changer du
jour au lendemain leurs habitudes c'est
quelque chose qui prend beaucoup de
temps et donc l'accompagneur a but être
mieux mieux fait la ministre quand même
madame Guilbaud dit il y a une foule de
mesure qui sont déjà en place et qui ont
été expliqués d'ailleurs sur le site du
ministère des Transports et de la
mobilité durable il y a des
stationnements institutifs et des lignes
d'autobus qui sont dédiées et qui sont
offerts gratuitement il y a des voies
réservées sur l'autoroute 20 et on va
s'ajuster après les premières heures de
pointe les premiers jours mon analysant
est-ce que ça ensemble suffisant comme
explication comme mesure d'atténuation
je dirais que non toutefois on est à
trois jours là de la fameuse date
fatidique donc c'est sûr et certain que
c'est quand même rassurant de savoir que
le tout le monde va être à l'écoute et
regarder un peu qu'est-ce qui se passe
en cours de route avec les avec les
jours à venir mais on parle pas non plus
de toutes les mesures qui devraient
toucher les villes avoisinantes on parle
beaucoup de des automobilistes qui vont
prendre le tunnel mais qu'est-ce qui se
passe par exemple dans l'est de Montréal
ou le transport en commun il est pas
suffisamment développé où il y a des
travaux de voirie en ce moment sur la
ruche Laga qui vont durer jusqu'en 2024
donc tout seul avait impacter beaucoup
plus que juste les utilisateurs du
tunnel et un moment donné Fanny on a
beau dire bon c'est sur le site puis on
va on vous l'expliquer est-ce que les
gens vont le faire est-ce que les
travailleurs vont répondre à l'appel du
transport en commun puis du covoiturage
puis du télétravail
il y a des chances que oui il y a une
lumière au bout du tunnel si on peut
dire puis je peux comprendre la posture
de la ministre à cet égard là parce que
quand on regarde les études qui ont été
faits à l'égard des fermetures de ponts
des fermetures de tunnels qui ont été
annoncés qui étaient prévus ces études
démontrent que les conséquences
catastrophiques qu'on peut anticiper son
poste pire que ça puis on se rappelle de
l'exemple le pont de Québec pas le pont
de Québec le Pont Pierre Laporte en 2021
il y avait eu des travaux on anticipait
une catastrophe ça c'est pas concrétiser
puis ça c'est dur au phénomène de la
demande réduite c'est le contraire de la
demande induite c'est comme si le trafic
s'évaporer donc en moyenne la médiane
pour ce genre de projet là qui sont de
travaux de fermeture il disparaît tout
simplement c'est que les gens ils
changent leur ils changent leurs options
ils changent leur déplacement ils
changent ils se déplace moins tout
simplement c'est environ entre 11 et 20%
le de moyenne ou de médianes de
réduction tout simplement du trafic donc
c'est possible que les gens
choisissent les options qui sont qui
sont offertes ceux qui peuvent pourront
le faire je veux vous entendre sur la
proposition de du PDG de la Chambre de
commerce de Montréal métropolitain
Michel Leblanc qui a dit on devrait
interdire l'auto-solo dans le tunnel aux
heures de pointe pendant la durée des
travaux Mona Lisa vous en pensez quoi
bah c'est sûr que dans le meilleur des
mondes c'est un peu une solution
évidente par contre dans la pratique
c'est pas du tout je trouve que c'est un
peu poussé tiré par les cheveux on se
rappelle que ces trois voies qui va y
avoir dans le dans le tunnel ou aucune
possibilité d'avoir une voie réservée
après c'est toute la question de comment
est-ce qu'on va renforcer l'auto solo
c'est sûr qu'il existe des radars comme
ils sont utilisés beaucoup en Europe en
France notamment mais comment est-ce
qu'on va vraiment renforcer ça est-ce
que c'est est-ce que c'est la bonne
solution selon moi non je pense
toutefois que c'est nécessaire
d'encourager les gens à délaisser la
voiture d'encourager les gens à
délaisser la voiture solo mais faut pas
oublier non plus que les personnes qui
transitent par le tunnel souvent le fond
c'est un choix c'est un choix qui qui
fonctionne dans durée de vie et de leur
demander du jour au lendemain de changer
ça c'est pas quelque chose de facile la
ministre gilbo n'est pas fermée à cette
proposition là mais elle veut commencer
par des mesures volontaires Fanny est-ce
que c'est inévitable qu'on arrive à une
solution comme dire on va laisser passer
que le covoiturage
la question se pose en fait c'est ce
sont des choix qui se planifient je
m'étonne en fait que qui disent ah on va
les étudiants on va étudier la fermeture
pour les loto solo ou envoyer le fait de
d'interdire le tunnel au camionnage
durant les heures de pointe donc je
m'étonne que on en discute maintenant ce
sont des choses qui aurait dû être
planifié avant puis si on offre si on
interdit l'auto-solo ben il faut offrir
des alternatives c'est c'est nécessaire
mais on peut pas faire on peut pas
interdire aux gens sans leur offrir
d'autres options est-ce que il faut les
gouvernements se
déresponsabilise en demandant aux
automobilistes finalement de s'organiser
c'est l'argument de prof morancy
effectivement quand on regarde
qu'historia si Catherine morancy qui a
dit ça ce matin à la radio exactement
en fait si on regarde ce qui se fait
ailleurs le gouvernement provincial les
gouvernements provinciaux et les
gouvernements éthiques interviennent
directement dans la planification dans
les investissements et de manière plus
coercitive là on regarde tous les cas à
succès au Canada aux États-Unis c'est
une forte intervention non seulement
dans les investissements en
planification en exploitation en
infrastructure mais aussi des mesures
dissuasives
c'est sûr et certain que j'ai
l'impression que le gouvernement se
déresponsabilise parce que mais en fait
il manque de temps donc ils ont pas le
choix en fait d'utiliser cette
d'utiliser cette approche là mais je
pense que les automobilistes aussi plus
ça va aller plus de même vont essayer je
pense qu'en ce moment je pense juste
avant le passage on voyait que les ça se
met incitatifs étaient vides mais plus
ils vont vivre pour la réalité d'aller
de passer dans le tunnel que les temps
soient tellement changeant je pense que
demain aussi vont essayer d'utiliser les
différentes alternatives là Geneviève
Guilbaud a rencontré les associations de
camionnage pour tenter de les convaincre
aussi de revoir leurs horaires le
Premier ministre le goût évoquait même
l'idée de privilégier le transport de
marchandises la nuit Mona Lisa d'abord
est-ce que ça vous semble réalise comme
solution pas tout à fait parce que là
dedans on prend on ne tient pas compte
de l'enjeu de pénurie de main d'oeuvre
qui est important en ce moment dans le
dans l'industrie qui dit la nuit dit
prime de nuit d'y trouver des
camionnettes qui sont disponibles pour
effectuer ces transports là la nuit
c'est pas chose facile par contre
effectivement si on regarde le revers de
la médaille c'est sûr que la nuit est
moins d'achalandage en tunnel donc c'est
plus facile de de prioriser cette avenue
là mais c'est une augmentation des coûts
c'est changer complètement la chaîne
logistique et on voit plusieurs
compagnies de transport essayer de
changer un peu leur approche de louer
des stationnements à d'autres endroits
et de des entendre par exemple avec le
avec le port de Montréal pour effectuer
les livraisons le samedi mais elle a les
délais de livraison sont plus longs les
coûts sont plus élevés donc voilà ça va
être complexe est-ce qu'on a sous-estimé
les implications économiques de tout
chantier Fanny
c'est certain que le chantier on ne
sous-estimé s'est passé de 500 millions
à 900 millions puis en plus il y a
toutes les mesures d'atténuation donc ça
vraiment un impact sur la compétitivité
l'attractivité de la région puis je
pense que le problème est vraiment
structurel dans la grande région de
Montréal les taux de d'occupation des
transports collectifs sont à 70% de ce
qui était prépondément donc je pense
qu'il faut vraiment revoir la manière
dont planifie les transports dans la
région puis je pense que des mesures qui
passent par la responsabilité des
employeurs pourraient être très porteuse
parce que ce sont eux qui sont en mesure
de déterminer les mesures qui sont le
plus adaptées à leur à leurs employés
Fanny Tremblay Resco c'est très
intéressant mon anxia prospère merci
pour votre regard votre analyse vos
propos ce soir merci d'avoir été avec
nous
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI